eleven of us spend nine days in
god-awful weather conditions
spiking trees five hundred pounds of
spikes measuring eight to ten inches in
length
you bastards go in there anyway and a
lot of people could get hurt
i mean this is not somebody who's just a
radical in college right this is
somebody who's actively working with an
eco-terrorist group
the problem for joe biden is that his
entire administration is predicated it
sits atop the iceberg that is the
democratic party and that iceberg
has been gradually drifting to the left
david shore who's a a statistician and
economist
he's of the left he points out that
basically all change in terms of policy
in terms of both parties has come from
the left since 2010
the the right the republican party has
been basically stagnant in terms of its
policy prescriptions
and positions since 2010 the democratic
party has been moving
ever more steadily to the left and
people of the left have begun to
acknowledge this they begin to
acknowledge yes we're getting more
radical now what they say is
our radicalism is justified and good but
there is no question that joe biden
himself has moved to the left and this
administration which promised to be a
return
to some semblance of normalcy might be
more normal
in terms of joe biden not tweeting but
it is certainly less normal in terms of
policy this was always the great
disconnect with trump is that trump said
crazy things all the time but
trump's actual policy was mainstream
republican policy
very often embracing centrist policy in
terms of spending proposals
his foreign policy was basically normal
hawkish republican
foreign policy although with more of a
sort of
isolationist bent than traditional
american republican foreign policy
his tax policy was very traditional
republican policy
his domestic regulatory policy was
traditional republican policy joe biden
however has stacked his administration
with people who are radicals
his democratic party has decided to
overthrow
years decades actually of bipartisan
agreement on key issues
so for example nancy pelosi has
announced that the democratic party is
going to ram through a revision of the
hyde amendment the height amendment has
been an agreement between democrats and
republicans that regardless of where you
stand on abortion
federal tax dollars should not be used
for individual abortions
federal tax dollars if you're going to
spend them at planned parenthood they're
supposed to be used to cover
planned parenthood's front office now we
all understand that there's a little bit
of a legal lie going on here that money
is fungible if you send planned
parenthood money to cover
its front office staff then all the
money they were going to use for their
front office staff they are now going to
use for abortions but
at least the idea was that there was an
agreement between republicans and
democrats
that abortion should not be federally
funded democrats however have decided
that abortion is an overt good
it is not that abortion ought to be safe
legal and rare as in the clinton days
which at least
allowed for the possibility of some
crossover between left and right on
abortion policy because after all
if the left acknowledges that abortion
is a moral tragedy then even if they
want it to remain legal they are not at
least quote unquote pro-abortion but the
democratic party has now embraced an
abortion these sort of
shout your abortion idea be proud of
your abortion abortion
isn't merely a horrible thing that
sometimes is necessary as democrats used
to argue
now abortion is a point of pride you
can't actually
usher yourself into the full flower of
womanhood another word that has no
meaning according to the democrats
unless you have an abortion lena dunham
said this uh fairly openly a few years
ago when she said she wishes she had had
an abortion
so that she could have really enjoyed
the full freedoms of the law well nancy
pelosi
and joe biden both of whom used to
basically go along with the consensus
view that federal taxpayer dollars
should not be used for abortion now
they've reversed themselves joe biden
did it a couple of years ago
he had said that he was in favor of the
height amendment then he reversed
himself because he needed to move to the
left
now nancy pelosi is saying the same
thing now one of the great i think
annoyances for many
catholics in the country watching joe
biden and nancy pelosi say this stuff is
that very often they say this stuff in
the name of catholicism
and i'm going to go with the pope and
jesus not super huge on abortion i don't
have to be
a christianity expert to point out that
abortion has been
sort of a major issue for the catholic
church since literally
the entire catholic church but here's
nancy pelosi making the case
that abortion is actually a positive
good taxpayers should fund abortion
she starts off by talking about her
catholic faith and then she's like ah my
catholic thing
and she just kind of throws it out the
window here we go
as a devout catholic and mother of five
in six years uh i feel that god blessed
my husband and me
with our beautiful family five children
six years almost to the day
but that may not be what we should it's
not up to me to
dictate that that's what other people
should do
and it's an issue of fairness and
uh justice for poor women in in our
country
it's an issue of fairness and justice
that poor women should be able to kill
babies in the womb sure
my husband and i were blessed by god
with these five or six kids but if we've
been if we've been
poor and if we just want to kill one of
them well
who are we to judge so the democratic
party in terms of policy has moved
in pretty radical directions here and
it's been true throughout the
administration this is why they've
embraced quote unquote equity as the
core
of all of the things they do from nasa
to commerce from education to the
department of the interior from
transportation
to whatever is joe biden's policy
prescription of the day it's all equity
and equity of course is a code word for
group
social justice on the basis of race this
has been embraced by the entire obama
admin
but i say obama but it really is the
biden administration which is the third
part of the obama administration here's
gina raimondo biden's commerce secretary
yesterday saying that equity is at the
core of her commerce strategy which
again i don't know why it's not the
department of equity in fact the
department of equity would be
unconstitutional because equity itself
as a concept
violates the equal protection clause of
the 14th amendment but
here is here is gina raimondo claiming
that equity ought to be at the center of
commerce
our number one investment priority is
equity
and as our team decides which these are
this is a competitive grant process
by the way i think that the fact of the
competition
will help communities to come together
as a community
and and put their best ideas forward in
order to qualify to get the money you
have to prove to us
that equity you'll have an equity lens
okay that's insane so she's saying we
have a competitive process but the
competitive process is not about
best product lowest price which normally
when you're negotiating on the behalf of
taxpayers for grant money that's usually
the process
now the process is about can you prove
to us that you mirror our political
priorities can you prove to us that
you're committed
to equity and by equity we mean you have
a certain number of black people on your
board and we have a certain number of
gay people on your board
that's that's how we're going to make
sure that equity is assured right this
is very radical stuff from the federal
government and the federal government
not only has no business doing this it's
pretty clearly violative of
constitutional principles
first of all it should be violative of
constitutional principles to force
taxpayers to pay for abortions it should
also it's clearly violative
of constitutional federal principles as
well as the civil rights act of 1964
to suggest that the federal government
can dole out money to particular
businesses based on how many people of a
particular melanin level
are on their board right that that
i'm unaware of a time in american
history where the people who are
stumping in favor of racial
discrimination
are the good guys but this is the biden
administration and they have at the top
this man approaching senility who is
able to put sort of a friendly face on
this sort of stuff but the underlying
policy
is really really radical and many of the
people who are staffing the
administration
are really radical it's kind of amazing
the kinds of people who have been
staffed in this administration and we've
seen the doj staffed by absolute
radicals and people
who have written extraordinarily
racially radical things people who have
been
openly opposed to policing now staffing
up the civil rights division of the doj
now we have a nominee to lead the bureau
of land management
right which is all about negotiating the
needs
of people like ranchers and farmers who
have to use the land in order to produce
and the and the federal government's
vast oversight of huge quantities of
land like people i think don't have any
idea
of how much control the the bureau of
land management has
over various swaths of state they have
oversight of 247.3
million acres 247.3
million acres and the amount of land
they have control of in each state
is utterly crazy if you look at the map
basically it's the entirety of the state
of nevada blm has control
not black lives matter the bureau of
land management has control over nearly
all of nevada
it has huge control over arizona it has
big control over new mexico
i mean if you look at the map it really
is amazing like once you get to the west
of nebraska
pretty much half the country is under
the control of the bureau of land
management
huge swaths of california huge swaths of
idaho
huge swaths of oregon
two-thirds of wyoming right so the
bureau of land management's a pretty
important position
so running the bureau of land management
you don't want somebody who's for
example an environmental radical because
if you have somebody who's an
environmental radical and
in charge of the bureau of land
management presumably that person is
going to crack down on the ability
of farmers and ranchers to do what they
want to do you'll remember that it was
exactly this sort of conflict that led
to the
standoff with the bundy family in nevada
you remember this
well now who is joe biden nominating to
be the head
of the bureau of land management it's a
woman named tracy stone
so who the hell is tracy stone it turns
out that tracy stone went in the 1980s
she worked with essentially an
eco-terrorist group and what they used
to do is spike trees so spiking trees
was something that radical
environmentalists would do
in areas that were about to be used for
lumber they would go in
and they would nail nails they would
spike the trees they would put spikes
metal spikes into the trees in order to
break the saws and presumably injure and
harm the people who are attempting to
cut down the trees because the trees
are more important than the people
according to the washington post one
spring day
in 1989 tracy stone rented a typewriter
from the university of montana library
and began to retype a letter the
typewriter was to avoid using her
personal computer
the letter was an anonymous warning to
the u.s forest service that someone had
hammered hundreds of metal spikes into
trees
in an idaho forest that was slated to be
cut down for timber
an acquaintance in her circle of young
environmentalists had asked her to send
it
after fixing a few spelling mistakes and
removing some profanity stone dropped in
the mail
it was a decision that has followed her
now tracy stone manning for more than 30
years
through her rise in montana politics to
become one of the country's most
prominent environmentalists and public
land experts
and now president biden's nominee to
lead the bureau of land management
the letter led to law enforcement raids
on student houses and a grand jury
investigation
her testimony in the subsequent trial
would help send two people to federal
prison
now that stone manning's nomination is
in the senate republican opponents have
seized on the
it's pouncing it's pouncing okay so the
fact that you have an environmental
radical
so radical that she was working with
people to spike trees possibly kill
loggers
her nomination is just another
republican seizing moment republican
pouncing moment
senator john barrasso republican of
wyoming who's on the senate energy and
natural resources committee said tracy
stoneman collaborated with
eco-terrorists
a bureau of land management director
during the obama administration bobby
abby
also said he opposed her confirmation
okay again this is an obama
administration official because of her
involvement in the tree spiking incident
and quote the fact that her initial
silence put people at risk apparently
she did not cooperate with prosecutors
in that case
however jeff fairchild who spent two
months in federal prison for the tree
spiking said in a phone interview
quote other than the mailing of the
letter tracy knew nothing was not
involved she was a bridge builder she
was a moderating voice in every
discussion she was always the one to say
hey look
loggers have families too well i mean if
that's the case then why did she send a
letter
trying to explain to people that the
trees had been spiked
by the way here is here is what the um
actual letter says okay in case you were
wondering again she wrote this
she or at least transcribed it quote to
whom it may concern this letter is being
sent to notify you
that the post office sale in idaho has
been spiked heavily
the reasoning for this action is that
this place this piece of land is very
special to the earth
it is home to the elk deer mountain
lions birds and especially the trees
like the lore actually speaks for the
trees the project required that's
11 of us spent nine days in god-awful
weather conditions spiking trees
we unloaded a total of 500 pounds of
spikes measuring 8 to 10 inches in
length
the sales were marked so no workers
would be injured and so you
a-holes know that they are spiked the
majority of trees were spiked within the
first 10 feet
many many others were spiked as high as
150 feet i'd be more than willing to pay
you a dollar for the sale but you would
have to find me first and that
could be your worst nightmare sincerely
george
hey duke p.s you bastards go in there
anyway and a lot of people could get
hurt
and this is pretty wild stuff
and her history is i think pretty
dispositive of the fact i mean this is
not somebody who's just a radical in
college right this is somebody who's
actively working with an eco-terrorist
group
but according to the abiding
administration this is a great nominee
and by the way her her
her actual vote has now emerged to the
full senate on a 10-10 vote on a
party-line vote in this particular
committee
the notion that the biden administration
is going to be elevating
to high position as the head of the
bureau of land management there are all
these government agencies
that honestly have so much unbelievable
power that you've never heard of
like how many people particularly in big
cities have ever heard of the bureau of
land management
not many but if you are a rancher if
you're a logger
if you're a farmer if you're anybody who
has to do anything with the land
anywhere west of nebraska
then not only have you heard of the
bureau of land management they basically
can wreck your life
and the person that the bible
administration wants to elevate to this
position of unbelievable power
is a person who used to spike trees on
behalf of radical environmentalists or
at least defend
those who are spiking trees
the atmosphere was so tense at the 1993
trial of these eco-terrorists in the
conservative city of spokane washington
where stone manning testified defendants
were given bulletproof vests to get to
the courthouse
stone manning has long offered a simple
defense for her decision to mail the
anonymous letter
on the sabotage in the clearwater
national forest about two hours from
campus
because i wanted people to know the
trees respite she testified i didn't
want anybody getting hurt
as a result of trees being spiked the
four paragraph letter she mailed
put it a lot more bro a lot more bluntly
jake krielik met stone manning in
washington in 1988 according to the
washington post before she moved to
missoula when they were both interns at
the national wildlife federation
a child of the beltway who grew up in
silver spring stone manning and majored
in radio film and tv as an undergrad at
university of maryland
but she was passionate about
environmental issues krilik recalled and
once she enrolled in the university of
montana's environmental studies program
she became active alongside him in a
local branch of earth first the group
had a reputation for extreme frontline
environmental activism and opposition to
logging damn building and other
development that threatened
wilderness habitat tactics included
civil disobedience and vandalism
activists chained themselves to heavy
machinery laid down before bulldozers
and cut power lines
their slogan no compromise in defense of
mother earth
mother earth krilik's earth first debut
occurred in the winter of 1985 when he
and others barged into the office
of yellowstone national park
superintendent bob barbie carrying
buffalo dung in a don't tread on me flag
she'd protest the expansion of a
campground and rv park into grizzly bear
habitat
he would get arrested several more times
recalled crelic quote stone manning was
a spokesperson and someone who was
obviously very articulate knew how to
work with the media
certainly she was philosophically
aligned with what our goals were which
was to protect the last wilderness areas
in the northern rockies okay so senator
john barrasso
went after tracy stone manning in his
in in her questioning the other day and
of course he is exactly right
tracy stone manning collaborated with
eco-terrorists
she lied to this committee and she
continues to harbor extremist views
most americans find reprehensible she is
thoroughly disqualified from holding the
important position of director of the
bureau of land management
in 1989 while a grad student in montana
tracy stone manning collaborated with
eco-terrorists
who had hammered hundreds of metal
spikes
into trees in a national forest
by the way she did lie to the senate
according to john barrasso
ms stoneman and claims she'd quote never
been arrested or charged and to my
knowledge
the target of such an investigation
that's not true according to court
documents and news reports
stone manning was investigated in 1989
federal probe of the tree spiking
conspiracy she was subpoenaed to provide
physical evidence including hair samples
she admitted in 1990 she was an
investigative target her experience she
said was quote degrading
it changed my awareness of the power of
government yes this was happening to me
and not someone in panama so manning
also claimed
she later testified in a trial that
resulted in the conviction of a
responsible individual
that's part of the story but the reality
is she did not cooperate with
investigators
a retired federal law enforcement agent
who is the lead investigator for the
crime wrote to the senate
saying she helped plan the spiking and
was a target of the investigation and
refused to do anything to help
her intransigence set the pro back by
years only after she was caught and
offered immunity did she agree to
testify
against one of these spikers in 1993 and
this is who joe biden believes would be
an excellent pick to lead up the bureau
of land management because again
it's a radical administration the battle
for the culture is heating up we here at
the daily wear are making some big moves
so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment